cool okay um
yeah so as as you're aware um
there's been lots of kind of great
success stories for geometric deep
learning and that's been
kind of driven by the many sort of
domains where data kind of can live on
so stuff like molecules meshes manifolds
and all sorts of things
um
but in this talk what
i sort of want to challenge the kind of
idea that geometry is enough
so why am i saying that
uh
in in kind of differential geometry in
like mathematical physics we have a
whole bunch
of uh kind of structures
and there's a whole structure hierarchy
so
kind of on the left side we have what's
called like a topological space so this
is just a set where we also have some
sort of notion of neighborhoods so for
instance this point p you see on the
left it has this kind of yellowish uh
neighborhood around it and that's all we
kind of know about this about this sort
of structure um and moving kind of to
the right we we kind of have more
structures so
we can have
uh uh some restriction where we also
have these neighborhoods around each
point that look like a flat space like
uh euclidean space and this is what this
kind of map fi is showing it's kind of
mapping this neighborhood here to uh
something like a circle or something
like that like a disk sorry in in the in
r2 so locally uh everything kind of
looks like euclidean
and you can see the first structure we
were talking about so at the point b
there's no actually no neighborhood that
that looks euclidean uh just because it
looks very strange and basically the the
the space on the left is not the
topological manifold uh but the space in
the middle it's called the topological
manifold because it has these properties
um but now um these topological
manifolds actually this structure is
still not enough because for instance if
we want to talk about kind of things
like smoothness so when kind of a
surface looks smooth clearly the thing
in the middle doesn't look smooth um
kind of these these topological
properties are or structures are not
enough to talk about these things
because topologically you can show the
thing in the middle is equivalent to the
surface you see on the very far right
but clearly one is much more smoother
than the other so if you want to talk
about these things you need even more
structure
um and
uh what we kind of end up with is uh
what what's called like a differentiable
manifold or simply what people usually
call a manifold and it's only at this
stage when we're kind of on on the far
right of this diagram that we actually
have uh
you know like where geometry kind of
starts once creating this space we have
like tangent spaces to the manifold and
we can do all sorts of geometry but many
spaces actually they're not topological
manifolds or even if you're a
topological manifold there are some very
kind of strange looking spaces where you
can't put this kind of smooth structure
on top
i see there's a question
uh
is the arrow uh in the third diagram uh
pointing inside or along the plane um
so here that the arrow is just meant uh
what do you mean like the tangent space
uh one so yeah like if you were if you
mean about this kind of red uh
area that's kind of just a tangent
vector and and the red area is just the
plane tangent uh at that point basically
there's just the tangent space all the
vectors are kind of tangent to the
surface there
um that's what it's meant to show
um anyways this kind of mathematical
details are not super important the big
point is that you cannot always do
geometry uh on on any sort of space
because you need to have all these
structures and sometimes it's very hard
to get there or it's even impossible um
and this actually led to some dilemmas
in geometric deep learning so michael uh
bronstein was remarking in a blog post
that
graphs are kind of special because
they are the only kind of space that
shows up in geometric deep learning
that doesn't have like kind of like a a
continuous equivalence like a manifold
equivalent so if we talk about grids uh
we have like just the plane as an
equivalent if we have like a mesh we
have the corresponding manifold the mass
approximates but if we have a graph you
know what's what's the manifold then and
there is no manifold because graphs are
actually not even like topological
manifolds and
talking about small structure is even
further from that um so you know like
what should we do and this is kind of
like a limitation of geometry in some
sense because it's much more difficult
to apply geometry on graphs i'm not
saying it's kind of uh impossible and
there's lots of interesting research for
that but it's not like it doesn't it
might not come naturally just because of
these constraints
and
what i'm suggesting in this talk is to
take a topological perspective so
what does that precisely mean so uh in
topology we talk about these topological
spaces so the sort of things you saw uh
in in the first uh slide with the man
various surfaces
so a topological space is just a set but
it has some structure on top so it also
has this collection d of subsets of x
and these uh elements of this collection
we call them open sets so basically we
just define some sort of open sets that
kind of generalize the notion of like
you know an open interval or things like
that but the kind of arbitrary
sets
and these open sets they must satisfy
some some axioms so the empty set and
the space itself are open sets and
they're part of this collection d and
the second requirement is that uh if i
if i take like two open sets and i take
the intersection that should also be an
open set and also if i take two open
sets and i take their uh union then i
also get an open set and here's like an
example of a space x that's kind of
abstract um and i've just put here like
just a bunch of open sets on the right
and that actually forms a
topology so so that forms a topological
space so there's this open set u that
looks like this reddish color there's
this open space
set v and then there's the intersection
and obviously there's also the whole
space that is an open set
uh and the intuition is that these open
sets you could think of them as
neighborhoods they kind of provide some
sort of local neighborhood in some sense
for the points inside them so we can
talk about the neighborhood around the
point by kind of identifying some open
sets around that point
okay
and what i'm suggesting now to do is to
look at graphs
perhaps in a new perspective that you
have not encountered before as
topological spaces
so what does that mean um is we're gonna
kind of if we just think of the graph as
like a set of points um we can put some
open sets on on top so for instance for
each uh node v for instance like here we
just use all the incident um
edges and the the point of the node
itself and
that will form like an open set so this
uv similarly for the other node here we
have this kind of blue region um that
will be the open set corresponding to
that node and then for this edge in the
middle where these open sets intersect
if you remember from this axiom uh the
intersection should also be an open set
so this edge in the middle will also
kind of constitute an open set
um
and yeah once we have this we uh we also
need to specify that all the unions of
these things will also be open so it's
because otherwise uh you know we
break the assumptions we were mentioning
so that's what the perspective we're
taking and in what follows we'll see how
this perspective can help us understand
and develop better graph neural networks
um and in particular we're looking at
how we can use this perspective to bring
some new insights and solve some
problems regarding to heterophilia and
over smoothing in graphene networks and
that's something i'm going to explain in
a second
so the setting we're looking at is node
classification so essentially we have a
single graph and we want to classify the
nodes of this graph
some of the nodes are labeled so
we have these red and blue nodes that
are labeled but there are also some
nodes that are unlabeled and we want to
label those basically but we want to
in training we'll use those that are
labeled and all the features of all the
nodes which leave in this feature matrix
x just kind of the classic setting
and first let me mention this over
smoothing problem so what is that um
essentially people notice that for
certain types of graph neural networks
for instance graph convolutional
networks
if you just stack many layers on top of
each other you'll see that as
the features kind of evolve from one
layer to another they are getting
progressively smoother or more similar
to each other and that's obviously bad
because we want to classify these notes
so you know if everything becomes very
similar to each other we can't you know
we can't separate these features because
they all look kind of the same so we
can't distinguish the classes anymore
and there are some kind of uh
proofs for it that happens but anyways
we're going to look more into that
the second problem which is related to
some extent is the heterophilic problem
so
it was observed that many graph neural
networks actually don't do that well
when the graph is what's called
heterophilic so that means the graph
tends to have connections between nodes
that have different labels
um and in general like most graphene
networks they work well when you have
the opposite so kind of uh nodes in the
same class are tend to be connected but
different classes uh tend to be less
connected um and here's a diagram from a
recent paper where you can see that gcn
for instance when uh
the homophily level so that's the x-axis
so um
at low homophily and high hydrophilic so
that's the left side the performance is
pretty bad but as you go to the right
the performance increases has increased
homophily um performance gets better and
there's already some existing methods
that have been kind of improving over
gcn and kind of doing better in this
kind of a low homophily regime
and these are kind of the color lines
you see here but there's still kind of a
gap to be to be filled
all right
um
now let me uh
tell you a few words about heat
diffusion um so first just some notation
so we have a graph we have a degree
matrix we have adjacency matrix and the
normalized laplacian which is just that
formula you see there so identity minus
the normalized adjacency
and the node features as usual now
what i want to mention is that heat
diffusion is a very simple process
suffering from over smoothing and and
this heterophily settings so why is that
um i don't know if you ever saw like a
visualization of pee diffusion but what
you can imagine is kind of like you have
some temperatures over your graph and
what happens over time these
temperatures kind of become more uniform
as time progresses so like hot regions
will become colder and cold regions will
become hotter and kind of everything
stabilizes around like some kind of
average temperature
um and you can see why over smoothing
and roughly uh show up in this process
right like if i run this infinitely long
everything will converge to the same
temperature and everything looks the
same so that's exactly what happens in
over smoothing and with heterophilia if
you have lots of connections between uh
kind of hot and cold uh
uh
nodes
you see their temperatures kind of
balance out very quickly and they become
kind of the same representation so you
actually make
things in different classes that have
the same kind of uh temperature and you
can't distinguish them anymore so it's
kind of
the worst model you could think of if
you really want to kind of uh uh you
know have problems with oversnotting and
heterophysically and
let me uh show you something very
interesting so if we discretize this oil
uh this uh differential equation
and we just use like a time
discretization we obtain something like
here so the features at time t plus one
are the features at time t minus this uh
laplacian times the features at time t
um now we can also simplify this a bit
further by just
using the fact that x is a common factor
here um and we obtain this expression in
red now what's very interesting is that
in if you uh remember the graph
convolutional network model which i
think it was introduced in previous uh
lecture but in any case it looks like
this so
that's how it combines the features and
the adjacency in this formulation and w
here is just a weight matrix sigma the
sigma is just an only guarantee
actually by just using just some simple
algebra this normalized adjacency just
from the definition it's actually
the red part we were seeing before so
this i minus delta z so you can see that
graph convolutional networks essentially
they are like heat diffusion or very
similar to heat diffusion but we've just
put some extra elements on top like this
weight matrix and the sigma um so in
some sense there it's not really
surprising that graph convolutional
networks have
uh you know a problem with heterophilia
over small thing because they're
actually built around this process
that's doing very badly of these things
now the question we are trying to answer
in this paper is can we make this
diffusion process uh so heat diffusion
can we make it more advanced and then
build like a better graph convolutional
network or something like that so how
can we make this diffusion process more
powerful
and the answer lies in these
mathematical objects that come from
algebraic topology and they're called
sheets so let me give you just kind of a
very uh brief introduction to this we're
not gonna go in any details um but uh
essentially sheaves are just a way of
keeping track of some data we attached
to the open sets over topological space
so
if we have a topological space like here
this x we have some open sets in this
space and what we can do essentially we
can just glue some data to each open set
so we have these uh f of x f of v uh f
of u and so on
so yeah just imagine these kind of flags
as some sort of data like a vector space
or something of that right
um and then what we have if we follow
these arrows it's kind of a way to
restrict our view to like smaller
regions right so i have this data over
this big region but if i have some
subset let's look at how that data looks
in that smaller region so you kind of
have this way of
kind of ensuring data consistency and
looking at smaller regions
that's kind of the the idea and it's
just as what i've just said anyway so
now what we can do is uh by just
adopting the perspective i was
mentioning in the beginning where we
think of the graph as a topological
space
we can obtain
a sheaf over graphs so what we can do is
for each of these open sets associated
with the nodes and edges that i was
mentioning
we can just put the vector space so just
kind of stick a vector space on top of
each of each of these
uh open sets
and then what we have between these um
vector spaces these are the arrows you
were seeing in the diagram before we
would just have some linear maps so
that's all we have so whenever there's
kind of like a node uh or like this open
set
that's bigger and we have like an open
set that's smaller like the edge open
set uh we would have one of these uh
linear maps for instance
and
now strictly speaking this is not yet
the shift since we have not specified
what happens on all the opening sets so
these are just kind of some of the
opponent sets of this space remember
that we can also have unions of these
open sets
and we haven't actually said exactly how
these vector spaces look like and how
these snaps look like um
and that's
that's
kind of an entirely different story but
fortunately there are these things
called cellular sheaths so these are
kind of uh
you know someone thought about these
kind of things and they actually already
defined properly um sheaves over graphs
and they kind of look like this so we
were just this was just kind of a way to
motivate this definition but from now on
just kind of think about this uh
definition and you know uh
you can forget about uh kind of these
continuous shifts i was talking about
before
so
what are these so essentially we have a
graph and now instead of just uh putting
things on the open sets uh because these
open sets were in kind of direct
correspondence with the vertices and the
edges we can just put them on top of the
vertices and the edges so it's kind of
much simpler right um
so yeah basically what we have is a
graph with some extra structure on top
so for each vector
suffix vertex v we have a vector space f
of e so in this case this vector space
is just uh like the real plane so r2
that's what these boxes are meant to
show
um then what we have is another vector
space for each edge so that's the vector
space you see in the middle of this
diagram and
for each
vertex incident to an edge we have a
linear map between these spaces so the
vector space of the vertex to the vert
vector space of the edge and we have
that linear map there and the
terminology is that these vector spaces
are called stocks
and these linear maps are called
restriction maps so the name restriction
maps comes from what i was saying before
it's kind of like zooming in on some
smaller subset and then you restrict
your view to that so that's where the
word restriction comes from
um
so these are these are sheaves and i'm
gonna
explain a bit further uh the intuition
behind them so there's this very nice
paper by hanson and christ where they
provided a nice mental picture about
these objects that comes from opinion
and dynamics so essentially
you can think of the
vector features of the nodes as a space
of private opinions so each
node in this network is like a person
right and when there's an edge between
them these people communicate so person
v and person u communicate in this case
um
and
the vector space in the middle uh is
called the discord space so it's kind of
the space where uh their opinions meet
and they start discussing
and how this works is basically these
linear maps we have which are
essentially just matrices
they map a private opinion in the
dispersed space for each of these two
predis inputs in this case
and then these participants can kind of
compare their opinions in the disk for
space right so
essentially these linear maps are kind
of uh explaining how the private
opinions of these people manifest in the
discord space and it's kind of a big
like in practice right because in in
public we don't say always what we think
and we kind of filter our thoughts right
and this is what these matrices are
doing they just transform their private
opinions into public opinions
all right
um
and once we have this sort of structure
this sort of shift we can construct
what's called the shift laplacian so i
believe you're probably familiar with
the graph laplacian and
actually the graph laplacian is a
particular case of
a shift laplacian but let's talk about
the shift laplacian and see how it looks
like so
uh
if we kind of
uh so it's just a matrix and if we apply
it to a vector x and then we look at
node v what happens it's defined as you
see in this diagram
so we just go from for all the uh we sum
over all the nodes u that are neighbors
of v and that's what that notation says
and then we do this kind of very uh
potentially weird multiplications what's
actually not that weird so if you look
at what's going on in this bracket
that's just kind of the difference
between the public opinions of the two
neighbors right so
uh the first matrix time xv is just the
public opinion of note v and the other
term is the public opinion about view
and they just take the difference so how
different are our opinions and you do
this along all the edges or all the
neighbors here around b and then you
aggregate them back but you transform
them through these kind of matrix
transpose
and the diagram below
kind of explains how this matrix looks
like so if you look at the diagonal
elements you will have this uh sum you
see on the left
um and if you look uh on the right you
see this how this non like a typical
non-diagonal block looks like
and uh to notice also that this is a
sparse matrix so we have just zeros
these these blank uh regions are just
places where there's no edge between
uh the nodes
and
uh something
we can do is we can also be like a
normalized version of this laplacian so
we just take all the blocks that are
diagonals here we put them in this
matrix d and then exactly like with the
uh how we normalize the graph laplacian
we normalize this thing it's the same
kind of formula
and and importantly as i was saying when
uh b is one so d here is the dimension
of these vector spaces
um
i should have mentioned so all these
blocks are d by d if uh so for instance
before we had r2 so these blocks would
be two by two
uh but if this one so all these vector
spaces are just kind of a scalar
basically we're back in kind of the
usual settings so each of these blocks
just becomes one by one and essentially
we obtain the the grapho blasting so if
you look at the formula in the
definition if all these
uh matrices you see here if they are
just a scalar one uh you just
get x v minus x u which is exactly the
formula for
the graph laplacian
so you can see how we can kind of get
more general things in this reformalism
and here's another way to kind of think
about these things
so in
differential geometry if we have
something like a manifold
uh
we have what's called like a bundle so
this is kind of a vector bundle so this
is just a way to put some vector spaces
at each point on the manifold and one
example is uh just the tangent bundle so
essentially you put all the tangent
spaces at each point and you kind of
stick them to the manifold
and once you do that there is this
notion of parallel transport and
differential geometry so what's that
essentially if you have a tangent uh
vector at the point like here so if you
look in the kind of bottom left of the
diagram
at this vertex w uh so we have this kind
of
relatively vertical uh tangent vector uh
if we do parallel transport we can sort
of move it very smoothly along this uh
edge and move it up in in this other
vector space and from that vector space
we can move down again and so on so
there's it's a way to transport tangent
vectors and what these uh matrices are
doing in the sheath you could think of
just being like a discrete or like
sampling some points on this manifold
and these vector space are kind of like
these tangent spaces
and these matrix multiplications are
just moving or just moving a vector
space from one time just space to
another so it's kind of like a discrete
version of pal transport um so just a
way to to move things from one time to
space to another and if you look at this
kind of matrix expressions you see in
this diagram they're actually exactly
like these non-diagonal terms you have
in the laplacian so essentially
these non-diagonal terms are just
specifying a way to move vectors from
atta from one stop to another one time
did you space to another depending on
how you think about it okay that's just
that just to give you some meditation
it's not like super important if some
things are not very clear here
okay now let's actually start using
these sheets and under some interesting
things um and what we want to do is
study the uh expressive power of
this
what's called the shift diffusion
process
um
it's exactly the same differential
equation we have before like it looks
almost identical the only difference
compared to heat diffusion is that the
laplacian is different so now we have a
shift laplacian instead of the graph
laplacian but remember the graphite
plastin is just a particular case so
this gives a lot gives us some
flexibility to study all sorts of
diffusion processes so by just modifying
the shift structure we get different uh
laplacians and different diffusion
processes and what we aim to do here is
to kind of study uh what happens when we
try different shapes there and can we
use them in a useful way and just to
kind of visualize how this matrix
multiplication looks like in this
differential equation so on the left we
have this minus delta f the normalized
laplacian
it has the block structure we were
seeing before
and
now our feature matrix looks a bit
different from kind of the classic case
so we have this block these blocks that
are kind of d-dimensional so each
because
each feature is kind of a point in these
vector spaces we were mentioning so if
our vector spaces are d dimensional then
we have the dimensional vectors
and
uh that happens for all all the nodes in
our graph so if we can just stack them
vertically and that's a single stacked
vector containing all the features uh of
all the nodes and obviously we can have
multiple feature channels so that's kind
of going from left to right we just have
multiple columns and each column is a
different feature channel
and each row are all the d dimensional
vectors belonging to a single uh node so
now the diffusion equation is a bit like
if you think about these vectors these d
dimensional vectors like vector fields
instead of kind of diffusing scalars so
before we just had like a simple scalar
like the temperature or something like
that now we kind of diffuse vector
fields which is much more interesting
right and you could think of the scalar
case as a particular case like when
these vector vectors have dimension one
so they just become scalars
so that that's kind of the intuition and
there is kind of like some uh minimal
thing we can say about this diffusion
process because it's kind of like a
classic result so if we just run this
diffusion infinitely long
what happens is essentially we project
the initial conditions so what we have
at time zero into the kernel of the
normal of the normalized laplacian so
remember from linear algebra the kernel
of the matrix is just
all the vectors that that matrix maps to
zero so basically in the end we end up
with this uh this feature matrix uh that
when we multiply by by delta f we get
zero so all the columns multiplied by
delta f yields zero so that's all that
means
okay any questions so far
all right i'll just go on then but yeah
feel free to interrupt if you have
questions
um
all right and then what we want to do is
we want to see how different classes of
sheaves can linearly separate the nodes
of a graph in the infinite time limit of
their diffusion process so just to kind
of illustrate that with the picture we
start with the graph like you see on on
on the left so if you look at diffusion
time zero basically so that's just kind
of our initial conditions right so we
have this graph the colors denote the
labels of the nodes
and the position
of each node this kind of its features
so each node has two features in this
case
and i've put each node at the position
indicated by the features right
and what we want to do is
find the shift such that when we
run this diffusion process like you see
here
um in the infinite time limit
uh these classes become very nicely
clustered then we can linearly separate
them so that's great right because it's
kind of like
what we want to achieve we want to
classify these
uh these nodes in this graph so uh we
can find these sort of diffusion
processes that help us do that so if you
look at what happens at diffusion time
14 for instance which is already a good
approximation for what happens at
infinity because this process converges
kind of exponentially
uh we see all these clusters uh are very
nicely formed of different uh classes
all right now let's just do that so
first let's look at some sheaves where
these vector spaces are just uh
the real line so just r
um and we also impose some symmetry
constraints so basically for each edge
uh e
we want these restriction maps to be
equal along uh
that edge so remember for each edge we
have two matrices one on the left and
one on the right uh one for the first
node one for the second node and we just
constrain now well now there are scalars
because we work in dimension one right
so we just want these scalars to be
equal
and you can show this actually
equivalent with kind of having weighted
graph laplacians so these are just
laplacians where you put some edges or
some weights on top of your edges and
the weights here will be just uh
the product of these two scalars so you
can show that i'm not doing that here
but just to give you an intuition about
what we're looking at uh we also
constrain these scalars to be different
from zero so we don't want to have zeros
there uh just to start with so this is
kind of very simple class of sheeps and
they recover weighted graph phleblasians
so yeah thank you think of these as
diffusions with weighted graph
laplacians and you know you might think
okay i've said in the beginning that you
know this hit diffusion was kind of uh
very limited you can't do much but you
know maybe you think okay if i put this
some at least some uh weights on the
edges and we make it a bit more general
like this weight it heat diffusion it
might do reasonably right um and
to some degree it does well in some
settings so for instance if we can sit
there all connected graphs with two
classes so just a and b two sets of uh
disjoint sets with the two classes
um and we have this property that for
each node in the first class a there
exists another neighbor in the same
class so we just assume in one of the
classes any node we look at we can find
the neighbor in the same class and
that's kind of like a homophily
assumption right we we expect to have at
least some degree of homophily we can
always find another node with another
label in our neighborhood
uh it's not a very strong assumption but
it is like
some degree of homophily that's assumed
then we say that this class has linear
separation over all the graphs in this
class so what does that mean it means
for any graph you give me in this class
i can find your sheath in this class we
defined above with the diffusion and we
always separate
the
classes for almost any initial condition
so almost virtually any initial
condition in your peak will separate the
classes so essentially this model can
kind of do perfectly on these types of
graphs
okay but
here's something else that happens if we
just have bipartite graphs
with two partitions a and b and we also
constrain these partitions to be equal
so this is the most heterophilic graph
you can think of right because every
neighbor is
has a different label from you right
like because you in bipartite graphs you
are connected to things in the other
partition
and basically everything around you
looks different from you has a different
label
um then you can show that there's no
shift in this class that can linearly
separate
the classes of any graph
that looks like this for any initial
conditions so whatever graph you give me
from here whatever initial conditions
uh i cannot find the shift in this class
that can separate the classes so you can
already see that this kind of heat
diffusion processes are already kind of
struggling whenever we have heterophobia
in the infinite time limit so if we
diffuse infinitely long so in this kind
of over smoothing sort of regime now we
can actually fix this quite easily by
considering more general classes of
sheets
so how does that look like so
now assume we have again a connected
graph with two classes so no other
assumptions just any graph that's
connected
um and we can construct the sheaf as
follows so still like we're still with d
equals one so that didn't change
and first
basically for each uh
so for the first uh scalar along each or
matrix here's a one by one matrix uh
just to kind of make sure we're on the
same page
just set it to minus alpha e so alpha e
is just some constant you pick for each
edge e
and if the first node is in class a
and choose alpha e if the node u is in
class b
and this will look kind of like with
alpha e being positive so okay what does
that mean so we're kind of like in this
diagram you see here where the first
uh kind of uh matrix is negative so i
just put alpha e to be one in this case
right so we have minus one and one and
what happens when you diffuse
uh you will reach like a state where
these features are polarized so that's
kind of what diffusion will do we'll
kind of polarize the features so this
orange node will have kind of uh this uh
feature that's negative in in this
vector space and the blue node will have
this feature that's positive because
they need to agree in the discover space
so what diffusion kind of does is as you
diffuse these nodes start to these
people start to agree in the discourse
space
and because of this kind of different
signature the only way for them to agree
that this first space is one to have
negative features and the other positive
features so because of this polarization
you have one class have negative
features one class have positive
features it's very easy to separate them
right you just look at
you know zero is your threshold right if
it's less than zero it's in one class if
it's more than zero it's in the other
class so this is kind of the intuition
for this result
so this type of shift can literally
separate the classes of any such graph
so connected with your classes for
almost any initial conditions so we can
already see like it doesn't matter we
don't need any homophily heterophily
assumptions or anything of that kind
whatever graph you give us
we can solve this problem
all right
um now there's still kind of a an issue
here
and that's kind of specific to having
these dimension ones so so far we only
looked at kind of one dimensional vector
spaces so our laplacians were kind of uh
you know just regular matrices they are
not block matrixes so far
but if we just stick with this we have
some problems so we have a connected
graph with more than three or at least
three classes
and if we set all these uh vector spaces
to have dimension one then no shift can
separate the classes for any initial
conditions
uh and why is that essentially you can
show that what you end up with
is kind of like a one-dimensional um
uh
kind of a kernel right so we we said we
convert into the kernel of the laplacian
and you can show when d equals one the
kernel is at most one-dimensional so
essentially you're projecting everything
on a line and in the most fortunate case
you're gonna end up with something like
this where kind of uh different classes
are placed in different regions of this
line but still you cannot kind of
separate them uh linearly like at least
not with a single hyperplane right you
would need multiple kind of hyperplane
or multiple thresholds so for instance
for the blue class in the middle you
would need kind of a hyper plane on its
left and a hyperplane on its right to
separate them
so you're kind of a bit limited or you
need slightly more complex decision
boundaries so you can only achieve this
kind of pairwise linear separability in
the most fortunate case
um so
the solution is simply to increase d and
use basically uh that will also increase
the dimension of the kernel space so
essentially we kind of have more room to
kind of move in in the infinite time
limit
and that kind of extra room offers us
some representational width to do more
interesting things
so
one way to do that is to look at the
dimensional vector spaces
and for these uh matrices these
restriction maps now we're just going to
consider some very simple class so we
say they're invertible and diagonal so
just just diagonal matrices essentially
um and
now we have these results so
again we can have any connected graph
but now with any number of classes uh
see that let's say it's at least three
as before
um then if we just set this dimension
to be at least c then this uh class
has linear separation over over this set
of graphs so basically if we make d
uh big enough we can easily find sheaves
that can separate uh even more than two
classes so any number of classes we have
so we also solve this problem so
essentially we can kind of um you know
find shifts for pretty much any problem
now a question you might have is that
these diagonal restriction maps are you
know kind of simple so you know what
happens if we perhaps use some more
complicated maps so for instance
something we could do is
uh consider these bundles i was
mentioning so in this bundle case
uh when you have these discrete vector
bundles uh you restrict by definition
that's what it means to have these
matrices to be orthogonal matrices so
these are d by d matrices that are
orthogonal
and again what you can show here is you
can kind of make more efficient use of
your space so if you have d that's two
and four
then you can classify up to two d
classes right so you can kind of use
less space to class far more classes
um and to give you like an example again
here's an example of diffusion process
here we have four classes and we're in
2d right
and
we can find the shift that kind of
clusters all the
uh classes like this and we can legally
separate all these four classes if you
look at the last picture so that's kind
of like let's say a visual proof of of
this result at least for d equals
all right
so that's kind of uh the end of the
theoretical part and um my main takeaway
from here is that different classes of
shifts induce diffusion processes with
different capabilities so we sort of
seen how going from some very simple
sheeps
that kind of you know give us weighted
graph laplacians or very simple things
like that but those very simple things
are currently used in practice uh we can
see that in that setting we're quite
limited but as we make these sheaves
increasingly general and more
complicated we have kind of more power
to do other things and to solve other
kinds of problems
so
this is a bit like in geometry where if
you have like different geometries for
some manifold or whatever you have kind
of different types of diffusions on that
manifold so that's kind of the intuition
um and also something very important to
mention is that essentially any node
classification problem
can be reduced to performing diffusion
with the right shift right so basically
for any node classification problem you
have on a connected graph i can always
find the sheath
that will uh kind of solved that
classification problem i just put the
shift over the graph run diffusion
i can separate everything
um this doesn't mean it's easy to find
that chief but in principle you'll
always have such a shift which is
something useful to know
okay
now uh we're kind of moving on to more
practical things and uh seeing how we
can actually use the shapes in practice
so
something that
you might wonder is you know like where
do we get these chips from or no one
gives us a sheet right like we never
have a shift data set like we always
have graphic descent so someone gives us
a graph with some pictures on top but no
one's ever going to give us a sheep
structure on that graph in general right
so
then there's a natural question how can
we actually make use of all these things
with that limitation in mind and what we
are proposing in this paper is to learn
these shapes so
we just learn them from the features
and from the structure of the graph
so how do we do that and what does it
exactly mean to learn a sheep so what it
means to learn a specific essentially
just learning these matrices right like
for the vector spaces you just pick some
b like beforehand like a hyper parameter
so again in this image d equals two
because these are kind of two
dimensional boxes uh vector spaces right
and uh
once you pick your d all that's left to
do is decide what these matrices should
be
um
so this f v e and this f u e uh for each
edge e right and what we can do is we
can just take
a parametric function uh and it will be
a neural network in general so
uh like uh this uh phi here uh that that
you see
in equation three and this is matrix
values and what's what it's going to do
first it takes as the first input the
features of node v and there's the
second input the features of node u and
it will produce you a matrix
and that will be the matrix
on the left so this f v e
uh if you swap the order of these two
things it will give you the second
matrix uh the matrix on the right so
this f u triangle e um and that's it
right like we we can just take this
function and we go at all the edges in
our graph we plug in the features of the
nodes that form that edge right on the
boundary of that edge and we just get
all these matrices for all the edges and
that's it we have our shift structure
and perhaps one way to think about this
in maybe more familiar terms it's a bit
like in graph attention networks if
you're familiar with that model so there
we also have a function like this here
but it's just scalar values so it gives
you the attention coefficient
instead of a matrix but we kind of
generalize gap in some sense
um to matrices right so now we output
matrices instead of scalars so that's
kind of uh
the intuition
and once we do that
um what we can do is we just build a
model where these shifts are learned
from data and we just
let gradient descends to learn what's
the best shift uh for us to solve the
task so it's kind of like what's the
best geometry or what's the best
structure we can achieve structure we
can put on top of the graph to solve our
problem and
what we use as a model
is a kind of generalized uh
shift diffusion process
so this looks a bit like what we
saw before with the diffusion equation
we've just put some extra stuff on top
similarly to how gcn was adding some
extra stuff on top of
heat diffusion so we put some matrices
this w1 and this w2
and
now actually if you just kind of ignore
this kronecker product in front of the
matrix xt
uh it's exactly like gcn it's the same
formula right we had just a matrix on
the right features
and the laplacian and the non-linearity
so all that kind of changes that we also
have this kind of additional matrix and
the reason we have it there is because
now if we work in some dimension d we
have the dimensional vectors and we can
also multiply those d dimensional
vectors with this matrix w1 from the
left so that's all that's doing
so it allows us to have like a slightly
more complex linear transformation for
the features but that's pretty much it
like it's very similar
and
in practice we discretize this equation
so we just work with kind of this more
kind of residual network type of
architecture
again this is just the description in
time of the previous model and it looks
very similar and so basically the
features at layer t plus one are the
features at layer t minus this
expression we had before now the very
important thing to notice here um where
this kind of sheet learning part
mentions shows in
is there's another difference with
regard to the shift diffusion equation
you can see that this f also depends on
time or on the layer
and the reason for that is because
uh we learned the shift at time t as a
function of the graph and the features
at time t and this function g is
actually
what we saw in the previous slide so
essentially you just take the features
you have at time t you plug them through
this function phi i was showing you
before you get all the matrices once you
have all those matrices you can build
the laplacian and then you can kind of
just use this model so that's the big
picture okay so let's look at some uh
results
so
first let me show you a synthetic
experiment
uh where we kind of test this opinion
polarization or like feature
polarization i was showing it before
so we have a bipartite graph again with
two equal partitions and we saw that in
this setting um
weighted graph diffusion cannot solve
this task so at least not with 100
accuracy it might do well but not 100
percent accuracy
so that's the theory and
what we're doing here we are just
considering a very simple model so
actually we just use like the model from
equation four here but we just set these
matrices w1 and w2 they have been set to
identity so basically just get rid of
them and
let's just kind of have like a sheep
diffusion process where the shift is
learned that's all we're doing here
so kind of a very simple version of our
model
and for the baseline we have this
weighted graph diffusion so similar
model but we just picked these sheaves
we were saying uh in the beginning
that you d equals one and you have this
equality for each edge just so we get
like a weighted graph and a weighted
graph laplacian so that's the
line you see in blue for the weighted
graph
and you can see that on the training
data set
the blur baseline is doing pretty badly
and also on in terms of test accuracy is
also doing uh pretty badly and the
access axis here is diffusion time
uh all right and you can also see like
with more diffusion time performance
seems to get worse for the blue baseline
um but for the kind of shift diffusion
baseline this
orange line you see here you can see
that performance improves as time
increases so you could think of time
here as a proxy for the number of layers
right so with kind of
deeper
times we have like kind of more layers
in some sense it's kind of like a
continuous layer
um
and we can see that we can sort of
address at least in the setting this
over smoothing problem right like we can
we just stack so many layers like
more time essentially and performance
gets better it doesn't get worse um and
what we're also showing here in this
green line
uh it's what we call an oracle sheep so
that's just uh
using a sheath like in the result we saw
before where we used like a different
sign for the two scalars
so we know that kind of shift solves
this task right because we have this
result
so we can just plug it in in our model
so instead of learning the shift let's
just use this ideal sheet and we can see
it obviously does perfectly and better
um but the kind of learned version is
actually also kind of keeping
uh up pretty well with the green uh the
green line so so the green line is kind
of like the ideal scenario
so we can see with learning we can do
pretty well as well and also to kind of
uh
look at kind of the interpretability
side of things than seeing what sort of
laplacian do we learn here uh what sort
of shift basically we learned here
uh is this kind of matching orientation
in the last figure i'm just plotting um
basically just prod the product between
those two matrices you have at each edge
in this case they are scalar because d
equals one so i'm just
plotting that product now before
training you can see because of
how these weights are initialized and
everything they are sort of clustered
around zero and you have kind of like a
typical histogram you see for kind of
randomly initialized values but after
training and we look here at this time
that got like 100 accuracy just seeing
what happened there um you can see that
all these products are negative which
means that they have opposite signs
right so like one
one um scalar is positive the other is
negative like like we saw in one of the
drawings before
um and we saw they actually recovered
this intuition that we had so
essentially uh what the shift is doing
is learning to polarize the features of
the two partitions so it's actually
doing exactly what we would expect it
should do and it can very easily solve
the problem by figuring this thing out
and
other graph neural networks can kind of
struggle in this sort of setting
just because kind of their kind of
underlying shift structure that's
implicit they use these very basic chips
that we saw in the beginning
um they they can't solve it
okay and we also have some real world
evaluation where
essentially we look at a bunch of not
classification data sets ranging from uh
very low homophily on the left so very
high heart neurophilia basically
to a very high homophily on the right or
very high low head roughly and or our
baselines are
kind of highlighted in in
involved here and we have three version
of these models i've seen i've shown you
so we have first a model that learns
these diagonal restriction maps we have
a model that learns orthogonal maps and
we also have a model that just learns
any matrix so just an arbitrary matrix
we don't restrict it
um
and we just plot here kind of the result
so the best result is in red the second
best is in blue and then the third best
is in this
uh purple color
and
we can see that in pretty much
all the heterophilic data sets
uh
these baselines these models are
actually doing very well and
outperforming existing models many of
them have been designed for hydrophilic
graphs actually and others have been
designed for kind of uh
smothing and this sort of things
and
at the same time we're also kind of
doing reasonably well on the homophilic
bench benchmark so those are kind of the
last three benchmarks where the
homophily level is quite high and in
general i think these models are in the
top three models for pretty much all the
uh data sets except for quora so these
kind of very uh interesting theoretical
insights have led to some very simple
uh but practical models that actually
work in in practice
all right so that's all i had to say i
also have a bunch of references here for
if anyone wants to kind of check uh you
know the details of some of the papers
behind this work
um i guess i'll have we'll have a way to
disseminate the slides later and you can
check this out so yeah that's all i had
to say thank you uh for your attention
and through the invitation to speak and
yeah if you want to reach out offline to
me here are my contact details i'm also
very active on twitter and you know
happy to take any questions you might
have right now